result because right now neither side  has done anything too wrong too drastic  but i i just have a sneaky feeling  they'll see magnus laughing as well  maybe because of the music maybe because  of the position who knows but  yeah either way he can't be too  unhappy it must be a new song coming on  something our scale has put in his uh  specialized uh spotify  list yeah we should imagine all of the  players they have access to the same  songs the same playlists so  no special disadvantages or advantages  for any player and uh it's nice to see  magnus in a good mood  and uh  he's enjoying his he's enjoying the  position on the board and he's also  enjoying the music clearly yeah and uh  one of the great things about the selfie  competition that we are  is magnus really laughing um one of the  great things about this selfie  competition that we are running until  the very last day of the tour final is  that we get to see  you guys enjoying the tour as well and i  have to